hey schön dass ihr dabei seid zdf heute
live inzwischen ist klar die
diplomatischen gespräche mit dem
russischen präsident putin haben nichts
gebracht russland tatsachen geschaffen
und am montag die separatisten gebiete
in der ost ukraine als unabhängige
staaten anerkannt und die menschen in
der ukraine die fürchten sich seitdem
vor einem großangriff von der seite
russland heute warnt der ukrainische
präsident jens g die zukunft
europäischer sicherheit werde gerade
jetzt entschieden in seiner heimat in
der ukraine und europa und die usa die
reagieren jetzt mit sanktionen und da
ist die frage was die bringen das ist
heute thema bei uns in der sendung und
eure fragen kommentare dazu die nämlich
gerne mit auf schreibt sie wie immer per
mail oder direkt an den stream
und wir können nun über dieses thema
sprechen was diese sanktionen also genau
bringen sollen mit dem
politikwissenschaftler und redakteur der
zeitschrift osteuropa volker weixler
nein entschuldigung volker wechsel so
heißen sie schönen guten abend
guten abend herr wechselt die frage ist
natürlich diese sanktionen das klingt
jetzt erst mal nach einem harten
einschnitt aber sind die das auch
wirklich in diesem fall die sanktionen
gegen russland
die sensoren ist die könne nur dann
wirken habe folgen haben wenn sie uns
auch selber weh tun das ist wie bei
einer operation mit einer
oberflächlichen kosmetischen korrektur
wird nicht viel erreicht und deswegen
stellt sich die frage wie sehr sind wir
tatsächlich bereit und wie sinnvoll ist
es solche harten sanktionen und das
würde den energiebereich den import von
gas und öl betreffen das diesen schritt
wirklich zu gehen um welche sanktionen
es da genau geht was also eu und usa
sich darüber legt haben da haben wir
einen beitrag einen zusammenschnitt den
wollen wir erstmal gemeinsam schauen
bevor wir darüber sprechen einen beitrag
von pablo sina la he
die strafmassnahmen treffen politiker
unternehmen und banken ganz oben auf der
sanktionsliste der eu jene 351
abgeordneten der duma die für die
anerkennung der selbsternannten
volksrepublik hans gunter netz gestimmt
haben und damit mitverantwortlich sind
für die eskalation sie dürfen nicht mehr
in die eu einreisen ihre vermögenswerte
in der eu werden eingefroren das
sanktionspaket umfasst außerdem ein
handelsverbot für russische
staatsanleihen der zugang russlands zu
den eu finanzmärkten soll beschnitten
werden und der handel der eu mit den
abtrünnigen regionen soll stark
eingeschränkt werden er kann sich
allerdings vorerst noch zurücklehnen
gegen russlands präsident putin
persönlich werden keine eu sanktionen
verhängt noch denn die eu will weitere
maßnahmen in reserve haben auch die usa
schöpfen ihr sanktions potenzial noch
nicht ganz aus bisher gilt nur folgendes
präsident biden unterzeichnete ein
dekret das geschäfte in oder mit den
beiden von russland anerkannten
separatisten regionen verbietet außerdem
stehen russische banken und mehrere
unterstützer putins auf der
sanktionsliste auch der handel mit
russischen staatsanleihen soll
sanktioniert werden von besonderer
symbolkraft ist ein vorstoß deutschlands
kanzler scholz kippt die
betriebserlaubnis für die pipeline nord
stream 2
sie haben es angesprochen sanktionen
sollen müssen wehtun deutschland hat
sich entschieden wenn es gerade im
beitrag auch kurz gehört also der
zertifizierungsprozess
zertifizierungsprozess für nord stream
zwei der ist jetzt auf eis also diese
pipeline die gas von russland nach
europa liefern soll ist das eine
maßnahme die jetzt eher deutschland oder
die russland gedroht
ausweislich geworden nach diesen
anerkennung der sogenannten
volksrepublik da nichts mehr anderes zu
tun deswegen kann die bundesregierung
das auch getan de facto
die sich um eine gas pipeline die von
vornherein keinen anderen zweck hatte
als eine andere gaspipeline existiert
und funktioniert zu ersetzen und das
bedeutet schlicht und ergreifend es
floss kein gas sei dadurch es wird kein
gas dadurch fließen in den nächsten
monaten jahren aber das tut niemanden
außer den unternehmen die dort viel geld
investiert haben wirklich will solange
die eigentlichen importe an erdgas durch
die bestehenden pipelines weitergehen
wie abhängig wir von dem russischen gas
sind auch da haben wir einen ganz kurzen
einspieler lassen sie uns auch da
gemeinsam mal drauf schauen zunächst
europa ist abhängig von russischem gas
deutschland ganz besonders das gut 55
prozent des bedarfs aus russland deckt
der zweitgrößte lieferant norwegen mit
30 prozent liefert bereits so viel er
kann und so bittet europa dieser tage
andere staaten um höhere lieferungen zum
beispiel aserbaidschan
verpassen vielleicht jetzt auch die
ersten fragen schon bei uns im stream
dazu zum beispiel möchte hier wissen und
im prinzip betrifft uns natürlich auch
alle in europa eine eine sanktion die
unsere ja unser gas unsere gasvorräte
betrifft also betrifft uns ja alle und
deswegen also die frage von nay hier
auch bei youtube wie wichtig ist die
einigkeit der westlichen länder für die
wirkung der sanktionen
diese eine partie einige die ist ja auch
da denn diese funktionen wie werden die
nicht einseitig von frankreich oder von
deutschland getroffen sondern es sind
immer die ursachen und großbritannien
ist trotz des austritts immer
eingebunden und verabschieden praktische
gleichen funktionen es ist auch mit den
usa koordiniert usa das muss man wissen
haben ein scharfes schwert noch als die
nämlich die
sekundär sanktionen und das liegt daran
dass die usa
sanktionen verhängen können für
unternehmen die gar nicht in den usa
registriert sind sondern zb gegen
deutsche französische britische
weltweite unternehmen das heißt die usa
sind nicht davon betroffen
single ist dass leichte bis zu verhängen
aber es sind arts hat einschneidende
folgen und das ist eben eine andere
situation als in europa selbst weil wir
hier ja immer mit bedenken müssen bei
der großen handelsverflechtungen mit
russland welche bedeutung hat das dann
auch für uns
lassen sie uns noch weiter ein bisschen
durchgehen da sind ja noch weitere
sanktionen auf dem zettel und zwar der
handel mit russischen staatsanleihen der
soll verboten werden tut das russland
dann wirklich weh
wenn man so ein bisschen
die situation ist so das gros der
staatsverschuldung scooter das sind 15
prozent und wir wissen ja diese
maastricht-kriterien in der eu die
längst gesprengt worden sind liegen bei
60 prozent südeuropäischem ende sind bei
120 kunden schätzen oder mehr prozent
staatsschuldenquote und russland bei 15
prozent man muss also gar nicht so viel
international auf den finanzmärkten
refinanziert werden und außerdem
ist es durchaus möglich dass die
ausländischen banken selbst für eine
refinanzierung des staates sorgen also
dass das
ist unangenehm für russland aber damit
zwingt man keinen politischen
kurswechsel in den nächsten monaten oder
123 jahren eine weitere sanktionen die
auf der liste steht also auf der eu
sanktionsliste stehen mehrere hundert
personen unternehmen was bedeutet das
genau für diese menschen für diese
unternehmen
komplett richtig und wichtig sie
bedeutet dass diese leute überhaupt
nicht mehr ins westliche ausland reisen
können das sind die komplette mitglieder
der der staatsduma hat diesen staatsduma
diese völkerrechtswidrige anerkennung
der
sogenannten volksrepublik johanns und
jetzt eben beschlossen hat es ist der
verteidigungsminister dabei also es geht
wirklich bis sehr hoch in die elite und
dass der präsident gut den wälder gar
nicht drauf steht hat rein wie funk zu
hören dass man immer noch etwas in der
hinterhand haben möchte und zweitens
dass damit ja mit dem höchsten mann im
staate um die beziehungen komplett
abgebrochen werden und das will man
natürlich verhindern sondern es sollen
ja tatsächlich zu recht auch noch weiter
verhandelt werden und für all diese
personen bedeutend ist dass sie formal
eben nicht mehr in den westlichen
staaten reisen können und ihre guthaben
die sie dort haben ein besprochen werden
das ist an sich sehr relevant denn sie
haben beträchtliche guthaben viele von
ihnen sind superreiche wie an der côte
d'azur in der schweiz in vielen anderen
attraktiven orten der welt geld angelegt
haben nur das wird sehr schwer werden
sie dort tatsächlich auch zu treffen
weil die dass wir durch nicht unter
ihrem klarnamen
dort einfach so angelegt haben dass man
hier allerdings marinovic auf dem konto
findet sondern dass es über verzweigte
finanzstrukturen sehr gut versteckt und
diese menschen wissen wir schon sehr
lange was da kommen wird leider ist es
doch so dass die reisen das reiseverbot
sie alle nicht mehr treffen wird sind
der alle geiseln des systems das sie
selbst geschaffen haben und dieses
system so schließt sich immer mehr
sie sind reich geworden durch das system
und nun sind sie so davon abhängig dass
das die schöne welt des westens zwar
verschließt aber es kann sie auf keinen
fall zu einer rupien sie haben diese
sanktionen gegen die superreichen die
sogenannten oligarchen angesprochen da
gab es auch die meldung dass
großbritannien drei von ihnen jetzt also
sagt sie jetzt nämlich genau die
vermögen einfriert und wir haben uns
heute mal informiert und auch noch mal
nachgefragt bei einer expertin bei dr
elisabeth schiffe von der lancken school
of economics was das eigentlich bringt
sehr dass für uns beantwortet für einen
scherz hat sich den namen die johnson
auf die sanktionsliste gesetzt hat weil
die ganze liste
bedeutungslos ist die drei männer sind
nicht in großbritannien die drei männer
haben keine großen vermögen
großbritannien durch hat haben die
sanktionen auch keine wirkung keinen
effekt keine folgen auf irgendwen dazu
noch sind sie wirkungslos im sinne von
wie sich andere egal verhalten werden es
ist ganz klar mit dem zeichen mit dem
signal des johnson innen
übermittelt dass ihnen nichts passiert
das ist nicht notwendig für sie ist
druck auf putin auch zu auszuüben oder
irgendwie anders der politik zu
beeinflussen
ein scherz hat sie also diese gezielte
sanktionen genannt gegen diese drei
superreichen von großbritannien in
großbritannien sie hat uns aber auch
beantwortet wann solche sanktionen gegen
oligarchen etwas bringen können
ich halte individuelle sanktionen für
sehr wirkungsvoll wir haben es auch
gesehen in den letzten jahren ein
beispiel in usa die 2018 funktionen über
einzelpersonen verhängt hat darunter
bauen die zwei oligarchen deripaska und
wechselbank wechselberg hat viel familie
in usa und der passte geschäftliche
interessen und immobilien und es war für
die zwei ganz schmerzhaft dass sie sich
nicht mehr frei bewegen konnten
was ist ihre einschätzung wie wichtig
sind also solche sanktionen gegen
einzelne gegen einzelne superreiche
das ist auf jeden fall kann man auf
jeden fall sagen wie sie sind auch
wichtig
die folgen betrifft in bezug auf die
politik was tatsächlich aus dem bereich
der oligarchen auch das regime einfluss
genommen werden kann da bin ich sehr
skeptisch und der kunde ist ganz einfach
der einfluss dieser
wirtschaftskapitäne also der sogenannten
oligarchen auch das regime selbst
ist in den letzten zehn jahren
systematisch
zurückgegangen also sie sind profiteure
sie sind auch mitgründer in den 2000er
jahren des systems guten gewesen aber in
russland selbst wächst seit jahren
der einfluss der sogenannten
gewaltapparate das bedeutet der
geheimdienst fsb das bedeuten anderen
geheimdienst vor allem als
innenministerium
immer stärkerer einfluss dieser leute
und diese keineswegs liberalen
demokratisch rechtsstaatlich
orientierten oligarchen waren eher noch
diejenigen die
das alles gebremst haben und jetzt
verlieren sie zusätzlich einen einfluss
man muss sie trotzdem mit diesen
funktionen belegen aber eine politische
wirkung auf das aggressive außen
verhalten russlands um erwarte ich
leider auch nicht es gibt ja dann aber
auch tatsächlich reiche menschen bei uns
die durch geschäfte mit russland reicher
werden stichwort gerhard schröder ist
das irgendwie ein thema könnte selbst
auf solche menschen vielleicht auch eine
sanktion zu kommen in zukunft oder ist
das total abwegig
warum sollte man die agenda verständlich
ist auch was nur eine symbolische fragen
es wäre zu fragen inwiefern das mit
rechtsstaatlichen mitteln zu erreichen
ist das kann ich als nichtjurist so
jetzt nicht beantworten ich kann nur
sagen dass die sache dass es tatsächlich
rechtsstaatlich abläuft und enormer
wichtigkeit ist wenn bei allen
werden die aktion des westens weiterhin
sehr stark auch beobachtet und jede
frage wo man sich eine größte gibt und
den eigenen werten in eigenen
vorgaben wie man ja auch machen möchte
neben den bezug auf demokratie und
rechtsstaatlichkeit jeder verstoß dort
wird genauestens beobachtet und da wird
sofort eine gelegenheit gegeben in die
kerbe zu schlagen also ja man soll das
diskutieren solche sanktionen auch gegen
westliche profiteure aber sehr genau
darauf achten dass dort alles juristisch
sauberen rahmen bleiben wenn wir jetzt
noch einmal auf die verschiedenen
sanktionsmittel allgemein und deren
auswirkungen kommen auch noch eine frage
bei uns aus dem stream bei youtube
möchte pokémon wissen hätten die
sanktionen nicht härter sein müssen um
russland wirklich zutreffen oder anders
gefragt hat russland durch seinen
schritt der anerkennung die sanktionen
abgeschwächt
abgeschwächt abgeschwächt schrieb er
wenn es einen unmittelbaren angriff
tatsächlich schon gegeben hätte dann
wären die sanktionen schärfer
ausgefallen sie können auch noch einfach
ausfallen wenn dieser ans licht kommt
das ist immer das politische ziel
abgestuft vorzugehen wenn man jetzt das
pulver verschießt an funktionen und
lieber hart ins politisch in deutschland
und in europa durchzusetzen sind hat man
schlicht nichts mehr in der hand
deswegen mit hier schrittweise
vorgegangen
und das soll dann immer noch eine
warnung auch noch ein signal der warnung
seien die können noch mehr
momentan
sind die sanktionen nicht dazu geeignet
diesen schritt der anerkennung
rückgängig zu machen und sie werden
vermutlich auch nicht dazu geeignet sein
die weitere eskalation zu verhindern
und trotzdem gibt es praktisch keinen
anderen weg ist es das signal nach innen
dass man auch als signal der
geschlossenheit dass man 60 man muss
sich eben nur bewusst sein die erwartung
sich den kreml politisch damit zu
beeinflussen das ist leider eher nur
eine hoffnung bin nicht liefern und
blieben zum schluss noch die frage für
wie realistisch halten sie es dass die
bundesregierung aber auch sanktionen die
eu auch sanktionen beschließen könnte
die uns dann wirklich weh tun welche
könnten das sein
also wenn es tatsächlich einen massiven
überfall auf die ukraine wie großflächig
mit panzern mit raketen mit von
vorneherein mit der russischen luftwaffe
dem quäntchen
flugabwehr ausgeschaltet wird massive
eingriffe auftritt haben wird das kommen
und dann ist es der bereich energie und
tatsächlich
finanztransaktionen es ist das so
genannte swift system wenn tatsächlich
russland ausgeschaltet werden würde aus
diesem system anbietet es den gesamten
handel betreffen aber auch die
möglichkeit russland aus dem gesamten
balla handel auszuschließen es ist hat
massive folgen massive teuerungen
irgendwo uns
aber man muss sich darauf vorbereiten
dass man so etwas auch diskutiert als
letzte möglichkeit im falle eines
unfalls ein glückliches vielen dank für
diese einschätzung heute abend volker
wechsel danke ihm
wir wollen jetzt im zweiten teil der
sendung auch noch mal ganz konkret
darauf schauen was also auch die
auswirkungen für uns hier sind also auch
wirklich welche sanktionen uns hier als
verbraucherinnen und verbraucher
wirklich auch noch weiter treffen
könnten und darüber können wir sprechen
mit frau professor dr karen pittel
leiterin des zentrums für energie klima
und ressourcen schönen guten abend frau
titel
und frau titel wer ist denn stärker auf
wen angewiesen also usa und europa auf
russland oder umgekehrt
das ist gar nicht so einfach zu
beantworten weil einerseits hat russland
einen sehr hohen anteil seiner exporte
und importe die entweder in die eu gehen
oder eben aus der eu kommen also er ist
exportiert ungefähr 36 46 prozent seiner
güter in die eu also seine exporte gehen
in die eu und 38 prozent seiner importe
kommen aus der eu adressen ganz
erheblicher anteil und russland ist da
insofern verbund war auch
andererseits von eu perspektive aus ist
es halt so dass wir nur
23 prozent
quasi nach in die
entschuldigung ich habe eine
rückkopplung in
ungefähr zwei prozent unserer exporte
die nach russland gehen und umgekehrt
ebenfalls aber entscheidend ist
natürlich was wir da eigentlich
importieren und das ist eben sehr viel
auch an energie und das macht uns in der
gewisse weise dann auch verwundbar haben
auch einen beitrag dazu vorbereitet von
dorothee schmid was also wie groß diese
auswirkungen für uns für deutsche
verbraucherinnen und verbraucher sein
könnten
russland ist deutschlands wichtigster
energielieferant
damit könnte der aktuelle russland
ukraine konflikt auch zum problem für
die deutsche energieversorgung werden
34 prozent unseres rohöls importieren
wir bereits aus russland 45 prozent der
steinkohle und 55 prozent unseres
erdgases
nun soll die neue pipeline nord stream
zwei nicht in betrieb genommen werden
noch bevor durch die röhre gas fließen
konnte
bundeswirtschaftsminister robert habeck
rechnet durch den konflikt mit russland
mit höheren energiepreisen
einer gewissen vermutung wird es auch
auswirkungen auf die gaspreise haben
einfach weil märkte spekulations
anfällig sind und die preise eben auch
immer eine wette auf die zukunft und
wenn ungewisser ist ist zu befürchten
dass die preise nach oben gehen die
preise sind bereits auf einem
historischen höchststand im letzten jahr
wurde das im jahresmittel für einen
durchschnittlichen haushalt fast 70
prozent teurer in ähnlicher
größenordnung stieg auch der ölpreis nun
droht der frühere russische präsident
medwedew mit einer weiteren verdoppelung
des preises herzlich willkommen in einer
neuen welt wo die europäer bald schon
2000 euro pro 1000 kubikmeter gas zahlen
werden
für wie realistisch halten sie so eine
drastische preissteigerung
es ist nicht auszuschließen also wenn
die bahn tatsächlich komplett die
lieferungen einstellen würde dann wären
das immerhin 40 prozent der gasimporte
in die eu und das würde sich natürlich
dann durchaus in den preisen auch stark
bemerkbar machen also wir sind nicht
mehr auf dem buch das wir im letzten
jahr hatten im oktober ungefähren auch
noch mal kurz erreicht haben im januar
die preise sind eine ganze ecke darunter
aber was er jetzt gesagt hat würde eben
noch einmal darüber hinaus gehen was man
auch sagen muss ist dass die preise
jetzt gestern gestern noch nicht sehr
stark reagiert haben also man kann auch
sich vorstellen dass da doch ein ganzer
anteil auch schon antizipiert worden ist
also quasi eine erwartung dass eine
einmal stattfindet in einer gewissen
form und sich das jetzt bewahrheitet hat
so dass die märkte nicht sofort noch
einmal reagieren die ampel regierung hat
wegen der hohen energiepreise sich jetzt
auch ein paar maßnahmen überlegt ich
möchte kurz nennen und dann können wir
darüber sprechen also zum einen soll die
pendlerpauschale ab dem 21 kilometer von
35 auf 38 cent pro kilometer erhöht
werden das ist nummer eins dann auch ein
wegfall der eeg umlage auf strom zum
ersten juli ein sonderzuschuss für
erwachsene hartz iv beziehende in höhe
von einmalig 100 euro und ein sofort
zuschlag für arme kinder von monatlich
20 euro ab juli denken sie das ist also
die richtige reaktion darauf um dem
entgegenzuwirken
also dass man sich insbesondere auf
einkommensschwache haushalte
konzentriert das halte ich für eine sehr
gute idee also ich finde es keine gute
idee zum beispiel die mehrwertsteuer
allgemein zu senken würde dann vom
millionär bis zum harz 4 empfänger alle
profitieren davon aber nicht gerade die
besonders betroffenen haushalte also
insofern auf jeden fall sinnvoll da auch
eine gewisse entlastung zu schaffen ist
die frage inwieweit die bisher
vorgeschlagenen maßnahmen von der höhe
her tatsächlich auch ausreichend werden
da bin ich etwas skeptisch weil wir
gleichzeitig den anstieg der gaspreise
sehen der strompreise der erdölpreise
also benzinpreise und eben auch
gleichzeitig sich das auf die inflation
natürlich auch auswirkt so dass das eben
für gerade hat vier haushalte oder eben
auch wohngeldempfänger doch ganz
erhebliche zusätzliche belastungen
darstellt die pendlerpauschale ziel
natürlich jetzt ganz speziell nochmal
auf die
autofahrenden
pendler ab die längere distanzen
zurückzulegen haben da wäre ich dafür
dass man das zumindest zeitlich auch
begrenzt weil das natürlich gleichzeitig
auch wieder den zielen der
energiewende des klimaschutzes entgegen
läuft da eben die meisten die in diesen
distanzen pendeln über 80 prozent dann
auch das auto nehmen wenn wir noch mal
auf unsere abhängigkeit vom russischen
gas schauen das ist ja auch nicht erst
seit gestern bekannt dass es die gibt
dass das so ist bereits 2014 hatte
kanzlerin merkel damals kanzlerin merkel
also eigentlich eine neubetrachtung der
energiepolitik gefordert wieso haben wir
nicht besser vorgesorgt wieso sind wenn
ich besser vorbereitet
es sind im prinzip schon in den letzten
20 jahren einige maßnahmen in kraft
getreten die auch versuchen quasi europa
mehr zusammen zu bringen also dass wir
austausch zwischen den verschiedenen
europäischen ländern besser funktioniert
dass man auch alternativen schafft zum
import aus russland also mehr zum
beispiel flüssiggasterminals baut aber
im gleichen zeitraum haben wir eben auch
erlebt dass die erdöl erdgas förderung
in kontinentaleuropa sehr stark
zurückgegangen ist das ein grund dafür
dass die importe aus russland
ordentlich hoch gegangen sind und das
ist wie so häufig ist wenn man in der
situation ist wo erst mal alles zu
laufen scheint dann ist der druck
natürlich nicht besonders hoch das heißt
jetzt ist die gute frage was passiert
jetzt und welche der maßnahmen werden
tatsächlich zwei jahre auch überlegen
weil de facto ist es natürlich so diese
maßnahmen kosten auch geld und das heißt
sie haben jetzt eine ganz erhebliche
kosten erhöhung durch die aktuelle krise
und würden dann im prinzip das ersetzen
durch eine quasi kontinuierlich etwas
höhere kosten und da ist das in der
politik immer sehr schwierig so etwas
auch langfristig durchzusetzen wenn die
eigentliche drohkulisse verschwunden ist
ich schaue noch mal ganz kurz hier in
unsere kommentare ob ich jetzt gerade
hier konkret noch was zu diesem thema
sehr aber ihr habt jetzt noch einen
kurzen moment eine frage zu stellen aber
wir kommen auch langsam zum ende was ich
natürlich gerne zum schluss noch von
ihnen wissen möchte können sie uns
vielleicht mehr klar in der
zukunftsprognose geben also wie sehr
werden denn die preise für uns noch
steigen
das ist schwer absehbar also weil wir
nicht genau wissen auch jetzt russland
tatsächlich verringert und sie hat ihr
habt die haben ja auch vertragliche
verpflichtungen also russland würde
quasi seine vertraglichen
verpflichtungen natürlich brechen wände
komplett das erdgas aus russland
wegfällt dann hat das natürlich erst mal
noch einen ganz erheblichen
aufwärtsdruck auf die preise
gleichzeitig werden wir natürlich auch
maßnahmen ergreifen quasi automatisch
die den verbrauch von erdgas wiederum
runterfahren zum beispiel wird auf dem
in der stromerzeugung auf quasi
automatisch auf grund höherer preise
kohle erdgas ersetzen klimapolitisch
natürlich jetzt erstmal nicht erfreulich
aber es reduziert den preisdruck
gleichzeitig gibt es natürlich einige
prozesse ob es in der industrie ist oder
in anderen bereichen wo man auch gas
einsparen kann das senkt den druck dann
wieder etwas aber jetzt genau zu sagen
wo wir landen werden es hängt so blöd
das klingt natürlich zum beispiel auch
im wetter ab dann wenn wir noch einen
sehr strengen winter noch 12 monate
kriegen dann sieht das ganz anders aus
als wenn wir den medien winter den wir
bis jetzt zum beispiel gehabt haben
weiter behalten also kann ihnen leider
keinen eurobetrag sagen vielen dank aber
für ihre einschätzung für ihre zeit
heute abend frau professor peter danke
ihnen
eben noch einspielen
und das stehen noch ein paar wichtige
termine auch diese woche an nämlich zum
einen wollen also die
euro-finanzminister sich am freitag in
paris treffen morgen einen
eu-sondergipfel und wollen da also
natürlich jetzt über auch die folgen
reden die dieser konflikt hat auf uns
alle aber vor allem natürlich hat das
folgen auf die menschen in der ukraine
und die werden fiel drastisch
drastischer sein als all das was uns
hier natürlich erwartet aber dass für
heute zu diesem thema von uns vielen
dank für eure aufmerksamkeit und dass
ihr dabei wahrt und bis zum nächsten mal
tschüss